first I wanted to say it's the only man
up here I want to say how it how
important it is to me to recognize the
power of women telling women stories so
thank you
[Applause]
um I'm gonna this is a question for both
um director and screenwriter so Marie
and Rebecca
I was rereading she said before I came
down here there's so much material in in
there that you can make a movie from you
could do 20 different iterations of this
story
what was the essential story that you
wanted to tell if you were debating
whether or not a scene was in or out
what was the test and what do you want
to include and what did you think was
not worth including
go ahead
well
I think we all wanted it to be
incredibly female
um and there was a lot of amazing
material in the book it's a brilliant
book and an absolute page Turner
but it would be nine hours in the
telling
um so my steer was to
not only be female but also to follow
the journalist's point of view so with
that in mind a lot of the material just
out
um and they were quite clean cuts quite
a lot about uh
the Miramax office and and then just
what was filmic so with those in mind
that was the first initial kind of
steer
and Maria you make a couple of key
decisions early one is you're not going
to show anything that happened to these
women and also you're not going to show
Harvey Weinstein's face
to talk a little bit about both
decisions and what informed those
choices
um
as you maybe know I I
at least for
um for me came comparatively late
into this process usually I write and or
co-write and I never experienced to
to read the script and being so blown
away by it and these choices to tell the
story out of the perspective of the
journalists
which entails that
we have contact to Harvey Weinstein hear
his voice or see this unexpected visit
in the New York Times was what they
experienced so um
this catalog of question in that
particular
filled with when you deal with such an
intimacy right
um
with sexuality with violence
um
I encountered this catalog of questions
with the project on Orthodox already and
I think it was clear with this
collaborators even before we met that
there is no depiction the depiction of
assault and I do think there is nothing
new to add to the world with another
depiction of violence there's uh but
there is something new maybe to hear the
stories out of the perspective of the
people who lived through it and really
see their faces also hear their
reflection on it and give it a specific
room and and space in this movie and or
unorthodox is also a story about a woman
claiming her power
um Carrie I want to ask you a couple
things first a scene that isn't in the
book but I think it's really important
in the movie and that's what we'll call
the bar scene
where somebody doesn't understand what
the word no means
um and to me it's a really important
scene in the movie be but it's not in
the book could you talk a little bit
about that scene and what that says
about Megan and work and men trying to
interfere with the task at hand that you
had a sad character
yeah it's not in the book
um in the conversations I had with Megan
they had that moment had not happened in
her life but she had had moments of
extreme frustration and anger and it was
telling when we spoke to Jody and Megan
about you know what would you be if you
um if you could be anything else if you
weren't a journalist what would you be
and Jody said I would be a therapist and
Megan would be a police interrogator and
so she clearly had
something in her that was very
um
forthright and
and I think you look at the sort of
series of
things that you know everything that led
up to that moment I think that's all it
is it's he's actually really mild but by
comparison it's really not and he played
it so well
um because you know I think it'd be very
easy to play that as a leery awful man
he played it so brilliantly he's he's
kind of annoying but he's not the worst
you know it's bearable but it's
everything that brought her to that
moment it's Trump and everything that
she put into that investigation that
ultimately didn't really produce results
um and it's her postnatal depression
it's the frustration of this story are
we ever going to get there we have all
this information and then one guy comes
in at the wrong moment and
gets it
DD this sounds like a flip question but
it's not and that is who was going to
play Ashley Judd in this film
you settled on a good choice but without
Ashley Judd there is no Story Probably
because her coming going on the record
if people have read the book and seen
the movie
it really hinges on what Ashley decides
to do because you talk about the
conversations about casting her she was
was she reluctant did you talk to her
justice Megan and Jody talk to her about
what this project would need how it
would benefit from her even if there
might have been risks
sure um
I mean I think we had this hope that as
many people could participate and if
they wanted to so the dream was that
Ashley would play herself the dream was
that Lauren O'Connor would really read
her Memo
that we would use ombres full tape
that we would um that that was gwyneth's
voice that's Judith gadrash's voice
but it was only ever
um it was just very carefully presented
and and asked and if someone didn't want
to do it we understood and then
fortuitously Ashley was in Berlin and so
while Maria couldn't be in New York
because of visa and covet and 700 I
don't know I mean the challenges
um she did get to sit with Ashley and
they had an amazing couple hours
together and at the end of it out she
said okay
and what about the audio from ambra
because I think we hear almost all of it
all of it was that something that was
part of a deal or you felt you wanted to
play all of it oh I you know I think
what was one of our rules like you're
not allowed to trim this because this
woman was extraordinarily Brave way
ahead of everyone else and she went and
wore this wire and she stood there and
endured that conversation and then the
police declined to press charges
um so it felt essential to us uh which
is not a traditional thing to do to drop
like a two and a half minute audio piece
in the middle of a movie but it wouldn't
have been right to to edit it and it's
almost as terrifying as what we don't
see just hearing it is almost scarier
bring I want to ask you about you're
working with inside a real Newsroom
you're working I suspect uh Jody and
Megan might have been around suspect
Dean might have been around as well
how do you separate you know what they
might bring to you in terms of advice
for verisimilitude
and make sure that you're making the
movie that you want to make that even if
there's a change here or a change there
that they're happy with it but you still
get to execute the story that you want
to make
well first of all you're just happy
about contribution you're you know you
deal with a true story and not just any
true story and um there's of course also
this moment I think
within all of us of
intimidation and a huge amount of
respect and responsibility for it and um
so the fact that Jody and Megan were so
tireless and answering all our questions
was beautiful because you can only
react to that with an extra round of
work and read a lot and talk a lot and
get all the information you you need to
at one point then say okay all this
knowledge all this all this dialogues
all this information is in me and I
carry it we all carry it right and then
at one point you have to decide because
not decide but you have to realize this
is not a documentary this is a feature
film this is a fictionalization
just the fact that Carrie portrays Megan
is an artistic choice and in the hands
of someone else it would have been
completely different so you have to jump
and latest when you start shooting and
follow your instincts and I have to say
Jody and Megan were not around during
shooting but they were accessible for us
whenever we wanted and I think it was
quite an exercise for them to do and
trust us with so much of the private
sides of the lives too and yeah we um we
were entrusted
Carrie I'm going to ask this last
question of you you can't really
forecast or predict how people react to
a film
but if the film has worked the way you
hoped what are the kinds of
conversations you might want to overhear
with people going out of the theater
what would make it feel like you that
you they got what this film was about
the article originally I thought gosh
that's crazy
um what a big moment I wonder what will
happen I had no idea and I didn't think
much beyond that and then everything
sort of changed within our workplace a
bit and you know conversations around me
changed a bit and
um I never thought about the people
who'd written it and then when I read
she said and I read the script I thought
wow it was these two women and gosh the
people that spoke to them what did they
put on the line for this and what moment
have we ever taken really as a society
to say thank you to any of them really
because the noise was all about the men
and the noise is all about with this guy
and this bad guy and this bad guy and
it's so much more about what these women
gave us and it feels like
I do feel immense gratitude releasing
the film every time we're in a room with
any of the survivors anytime we're with
Megan and Jody you know they put so much
on the line the courage that it took to
do that I think is worthy of a film it's
worthy of a document and it's worthy of
conversations that you know your
children will have I mean I think that's
it seems like it's an important thing
for us to have to be able to say this is
categorically what happened and how they
did it and we owe them something forever
because it has changed the landscape and
she said this is what happened
I want to thank all of you Maria Carrie
Rebecca Dede thank you so much for
making this movie
tell your friends to go see it in a
theater because if people don't show up
we're not going to see she said too or
whatever that would be
thank you all very much